this is a production of Cornell
University
all right thank you is apparently have a
lot of slides so I'm gonna try to go
quickly through them and I might gloss
over a few things but these are the
objectives for the talk I just want to
look at some basically examples that I
think illustrate why polyploids are
challenging to work with from an
informatics perspective and a biological
perspective I want to take the time to
use those examples to just look at some
of the tools and resources that we've
developed were adopted from other groups
and adapted to our needs you know using
them for our particular research
community but hoping that they'll find
more broad adoption and the last is
probably the most audacious of the three
bullet points but I I've been working on
abstract algebra as kind of a side hobby
and I want to try to make a case that
it's actually of relevance to
understanding how complexity develops of
sort of nonlinear multiplicative
relationships like those that come out
of putting two genomes together so we'll
see how that goes all right so just a
quick kind of overview of polyploidy in
general you know it happens all the time
seemingly in plants it's known to happen
in some other systems but waitwe in the
evolutionary past so if you work in
plants you know all about it if you
don't work in plants it's kind of a
weird little niche but you know there
are a lot of distinctions to be made
about types of polyploidy and how many
genomes have come together at once how
how recently it was and those are all
important for thinking about the actual
approach you're going to take with a
particular analytic solution to a
problem but you know and I've heard that
the thinking is that one of the reasons
why plants are so tolerant of polyploidy
is that most of them don't actually have
sex chromosomes and that facilitates the
combination of genomes they
but you know there are challenges at the
plant associated with actually working
out what to do with having multiple
genomes but after they've done that they
tend to be a little bit more resilient
and so a lot of a lot of crops that we
work with certainly have have come from
polyploid events possibly because the
gene redundancy kind of gives you new
opportunities we'll look at some of
those questions a little bit further on
I mean they they tend to occur in
extreme environments partially because
those environments tend to induce
polyploid formation but also the
thinking is that they are because of the
built-in redundancy they're better able
to adapt to such conditions so you know
as I said there are a lot of different
types of polyploidy so what one
distinguishes between a low and Auto
depending on whether or not the two
genomes that are being duplicated are
the same or different there's a type of
polyploidy that has to do with somatic
cells doesn't actually lead to new
species but you know basically mitotic
events not not actually separating the
results of genome doubling into separate
cells
that's endo polyploidy and then
distinctions are made you know in terms
of how how recent the polyploidy event
is and how far along the evolutionary
trajectory it's gotten so that it's
effectively become a diploid genetically
again and depending on whether you're an
auto polyploid or an a local at
polyploid that introduces Auto
polyploids basically all of their
chromosomes well the the homologous
chromosomes as we call them can
potentially recombine with one another
and so that introduces new possibilities
in terms of the genetics that need to be
thought about carefully so as Liz
mentioned that we're interested in
comparative genomics we've developed a
tool for basically looking at gene
content across species each of these
glyphs represents a gene it's colored in
terms of gene families they've been
associated with
and when you're dealing with say simple
species like primates and mice you have
nice fairly simple relationships between
the gene content in the various genomes
one-to-one relationships in general with
occasional presence/absence or copy
number variation it's it's pretty easy
to just pick out but when you're
thinking about comparisons between
genomes each of which has a kind of
separate
duplication history things become a lot
more complicated and so here we have a
few different species that have
different polyploidy histories some
ancient duplications that they share and
then more recent duplications that have
been separate in the different species
and so we've got a little track of a
soybean chromosome at the top we can see
that it's been through to whole genome
doublings one of the tracks is much more
similar that's the more recent
duplication event and then you've got
some more ancient events that are closer
to one another because they they're
doubling resulted from that more recent
event but further away from them even
even something that you tend to think of
as a small genome like a rabid abscess
has again chromosome doubling or whole
genome doublings involved with a lot of
gene loss afterwards so you can you can
easily see here patterns of
fractionation of the sub genomes that
resulted from these whole genome
duplication events tomato actually went
through a hex ploidy event and this this
tool you know basically allows you to
dynamically query databases for tracks
that have a certain gene content
associated with them and then pull in
from disparate databases tracks that
seem to have similar gene content in
terms of the gene family assignments and
then ultimately ask questions about the
evolutionary history behind genes that
have been aligned through synteny
together and they're their phylogenetic
relationships and so you can see that
out of those four for that particular
which was from a abscisic acid
responsive conscription factor family in
out of the soybean homeo logs three of
them retained that gene and it was lost
in one
similarly with tomato two were retained
one was lost and Arabidopsis also
retained two so this gives us a nice way
of exploring relationships among the
genes but the question you know that
still is difficult is well you know what
what happens to function as these things
have duplicated and went on their
separate ways and that's that's not so
easy to resolve so you know we're also
interested in well you know some some
polyploid species like soybean or
economically valuable and have a lot of
research that goes into them have their
own database resources with curators
pulling in information for the
literature can we make use of
comparative genomic techniques to
essentially take something like cow pee
which does not have that more recent
whole genome duplication event and
figure out you know okay do I have any
say snips associated with seed weight in
regions in this genome which I know has
sort of more or less two copies of genes
for every copy of a gene here and find
out well yes there there is a region
where I found an association between the
trait of interest that is similar to in
one of the homie August regions in
soybean where they also observed similar
variation so that's obviously a nice way
of taking candidate genes and figuring
out well you know have have I seen
evidence in some other species that
changes to this gene actually affect
rate of interest all right so here comes
the tough part making the case for
polynomials so just as polyploids
involve multiplication of kind of
independently behaving linear genomes
polynomials are kind of like that in
that you're taking together linear
factors
and if you think about it in this
direction it's pretty easy to go through
and use the distributive property or
things that you learned I was in Lansing
high school so I learned this for mr.
cotton mill you know you do the first
outside inside last trick and figure out
exactly how to do your factorization and
it's essentially no different no matter
how many factors you have you're doing a
combinatorial distributive
multiplication and you're you know
essentially taking the roots of the
equation and seeing them come out in the
coefficients in kind of interesting ways
that these are what's referred to as the
elementary symmetric polynomials which
means that it doesn't really matter how
you permute them you get the same result
and this ends up being very important in
terms of the theory involved in what it
actually means to solve a polynomial
equation so you know there are numerical
techniques that allow you to approximate
solutions but what algebraic people want
to do is to say what what is the actual
algorithm it can I find a formula like
this which I you probably remember the
quadratic equation you know it's it's
not exactly simple but it's it's fairly
straightforward you probably remember
how to get there you either memorized it
or you learned completing the square and
can read arrive it I mean it's it's not
too bad but once you go even to a cubic
equation things get really a lot harder
and this is a Renaissance mathematician
Tartaglia
who figured out how to deal with these
things by first performing a little
trick making and depressed cubic and
then eventually getting to a formula
that in some sense is analogous to the
quadratic equation but it's a lot more
complicated and you get you get also
interesting things with higher degree
equations like what they call cases
reductive lists which basically means
that you can have three real valued
roots but if they're not rational you
can't actually represent them
with this kind of representation without
involving imaginary numbers even though
the results that you get are not
themselves imaginary so as you start to
increase the number of factors of things
life gets interesting and going even
further it was it was eventually
demonstrated after you know people had
solved the cubic in the quartic it were
working real hard to try to solve the
quintic and eventually through the work
of a ball and yell wah they discovered
that in fact you can have fifth degree
equations and higher where you simply
can't represent the roots in any way
using that sort of representation and
whether or not you can get to some sort
of representation like that is basically
dependent on this notion of symmetry
among the roots and how how the
coefficients impose constraints upon the
roots whether you can represent
relationships among the roots starting
from what they call the field of the
coefficients so an example of that would
be cyclotomic polynomials which sort of
distribute themselves in the complex
plane around circle they have a kind of
a very restricted form and it can be
shown that any any cyclotomic you can
represent the roots in terms of these
I've specialized quadratic or not
quadratic but radical towers from the
field coefficients okay well there are
there are other times when taking
together a bunch of disparate things
that are simple to deal with relatively
simple individually and you try to put
them together and things get complicated
quickly even when you're doing kind of
the multiplication aspect of things so
this is a this is a project from which
many of the following examples are taken
an NSF funded project that we've been
working on to try to take a lot of
disparate information resources and
unify them in some way you know the
there are some technical challenge than
this
there are many sociological challenges
to actually getting something like this
to work but I won't I won't go into that
too much other than to say that meant
many of what I show would not be
possible without our collaboration with
many of these
groups so here's my first example
cultivated peanut its a recently formed
aloe tetraploid that was formed from a
few diploid wild species so the original
genome sequencing was done on the
diploid they kind of recognized early on
that the diploid were close enough
together that it would be challenging
using you know the tech sequencing
technologies available at the time if
you were to just sequence the tetraploid
directly to figure out which parts went
with with which sub genomes so they they
approached it by figuring out which of
which were the actual progenitor species
and actually one of them is for if
there's only one accession of this
species out there and they believe that
it was transported down into the range
of the other species by prehistoric
humans allowing allowing this
hybridization event that eventually led
to the cultivated polyploid so you can
see it sort of there amidst the range of
the other species so you get you can
kind of synthetically create what the
amphi diploid which are I think I think
it's just a fancy way of saying an aloe
tetraploid from these things that were
created synthetically and so that that's
the strategic approach and you can see
that there are some you know if you're
comparing chromosomes corresponding
chromosomes from the two they are
different structurally in some ways but
there's kind of a clear one-to-one
correspondence between the two
chromosomes so one one of the
interesting things about peanut is that
you know because of this extreme genetic
bottleneck that it went through they
think that there was essentially a
single hybridization event but ended up
propagating into all of the cultivars
that we have today
so it it's it's very non diverse from a
traditional allelic sense but
phenotypically there's quite a
University associated with things and so
this was kind of a question for people
as to how is it possible for such a
limited genetic base to generate all of
this phenotypic diversity so when they
this was actually something that they
they began to see when the diploid were
sequenced and compared to data that was
available for the tetraploid but
essentially what's happening is that the
two sub genomes within the cultivated
tetraploid are interacting in different
ways such that in some cases you have a
segment of one sub genome that's
replacing the other ones this is just a
representation kind of showing copy
number of the two different homologous
genomes so here here we have at the end
of chromosome 14 I think it is from from
a particular variety of peanut a place
where the B ancestral genome exists in
two copies and the a has been replaced
with it in other regions where a has
been lost
he has been retained or the other way
around so so essentially what's going
what seems to be going on to a large
extent with peanut is that different
patterns of this interactivity between
the sub genomes are generating this type
of phenotypic diversity and they were
actually able to show that they made one
of these synthetic crosses and kept it
going for a few generations and we're
actually able to reproduce some of this
phenotypic diversity with him that
pedigree so I thought well okay if that
if that's the case we've got the tif
Runner genome sequenced could we
actually see what they were showing in
that diagram using some of tools that
we've produced so here's that so called
genome context viewer again showing us
the two homologous segments of
cultivated peanut and then the
progenitor genomes and at this level you
could you can see some cases in which if
seems as though the gene content of the
two homologous segments is reflecting
the bee genome rather than the a genome
but you know it might it might be a
little difficult to argue that that
couldn't also just be vagaries of
annotation effects or miss miss
assemblies and things like that but if
you go ahead and select say if the gene
right at the end of the chromosomes and
then look at it within the context of
the tree you can actually see the
pattern fairly clearly in terms of the
sequence level relationships that indeed
in this case the bee genome genic
sequence is much closer to the two
copies from the tetraploid than the
other genome sequences and you can
interact with this tool in ways that
cluck claps down the tree of just those
genes of interest and then see that
reflected in the multiple sequence
alignment you can see various places at
which the a genome representative is
indeed different from the others at a
number of positions but of course if we
take another another gene from that same
region of the genome it might reside in
a gene family that's a little bit more
complicated so here again we've got the
B genome with the two tetraploid x'
taken from the same region and behaving
similarly in terms of tree topology but
there are other subclades of this tree
with different sorts of patterns
associated with them so you can you can
pretty easily using this tool again
collapse down to the set of genes that
may be of interest in your particular
context and then go in the reverse
direction say well let's look at their
genomic contexts and figure out not not
starting with the premise that you're
looking at things that are all synthetic
but asking the question how would I
group these things given their kind of
gene family neighborhoods inside
a way that I see the synthetic
relationships that exist among members
of this gene family so this I guess this
is the next gene down from the end of
the chromosome that I chose so this
would be our chromosome 14 genes and
then this is the other gene family or
other clades that you can see has kind
of a more complicated picture in terms
of the gene duplications within that
region and again you know some some of
the aspects of the way that those
sequences appear in the tree may be
driven by annotation sorts very facts
but we we believe that these sorts of
tools are valuable for people you know
who want to ask particular questions
that will enable them to browse the data
fairly effectively even in the context
of having these kind of fairly
complicated relationships between
between and within plant genomes so
we're really excited about our
development of this tool and hoping that
other groups will eventually start to
pick it up - alright so moving on to a
different example of challenges
associated with polyploidy this is a
genome sequence project that we've been
involved with for a number of years
actually more more years than I care to
admit
but it's been it's been a bit difficult
going both for technical and funding
reasons I guess but you know so we
alfalfa cultivated alfalfa is a species
that is an auto tetraploid and making
life more complicated still it's an out
crosser so there's a lot of diversity
within the genome itself it's related to
metacognitive cargo tranquila which is a
kind of a model of species for the
legumes and so you know if you if you
look at something like frequency spectra
in medicago you get a really clean
result showing you a sort of a plus on
distribution of your Kaymer frequencies
which is what you would expect from
single copy sequence content classically
and you can model things about genome
size and hetero zygosity which
effectively this has none using this
type of
set up when you try to do the same thing
with sativa things get a lot more
complicated in terms of the set of
camera Peaks that you're dealing with
and your attempt to fit models of those
kind of mixed model distributions of
Kaymer's present at different copy
numbers that you're sampling from a
large pool that you've generated from
whole genome shotgun sequencing well so
one thing that we did in that context
kind of similar maybe to the piano
genome there there was a diploid eyes
version of cultivated alfalfa that had
been taken from a tetraploid and made
into a diploid and we thought great this
will be simpler we can start with that
and then leverage it to help us with
when we're dealing with the tetraploid
itself all right so we had a we had a
lot of different data sets that we had
available or you know we started
thinking it would be easy with Illumina
sequencing and then as that proved not
to be the case we moved on to different
types of data so packed by a sequence
saying you I'm not exactly sure how
familiar you guys all are with next-gen
sequencing but you know there are a
number of different technologies not all
of them sequence based but they all have
kind of their strengths and weaknesses
with respect to getting at complex
genomes and so we've tried it tried a
number of things and one one thing
that's kind of a little bit unique about
Auto tetraploid z' in terms of using
linkage maps is that you do you do your
linkage mapping typically using say
single single dose heterozygotes would
be they sort of behave from that
perspective like diploid where it's this
or that segregating and you can just
keep your eye on the informative
haplotype and figure out how it's
segregating with other informative
haplotypes from the same linkage group
so I may be maybe trying to stretch that
algebraic analogy but you know as as you
as you think about roots of numbers that
are more than just square root where you
maybe you think about positive or
negative as you go to higher roots you
have to think about all of the different
directions in the complex plane that you
could be talking about when you're
talking about the the root of a number
so things things with genotyping get
more complicated as well so just trying
to get a handle on what the material was
in terms of you know what is it that
we're trying to assemble here do we we
essentially want to get eight
chromosomes like medicago house even
though we know there are 32 but for each
of the 32 four of them should be in some
sense homey oolagah stew one another but
at some level of diversity from one
another or do we really want a 32
chromosome sort of can genome within the
context of our single cultivar of
alfalfa you know and in some sense every
time you create a cross of alfalfa
you're gonna get a different combination
of these things so in some sense it's
kind of quixotic to try to get the
haplotypes but if your clone only
propagating at fuel you'll preserve them
at least and you can ask questions about
you know is is this technology suitable
for understanding issues of haplotype
phasing across long distances so
probably not surprisingly you know we
found that short read assemblies were
compressing things down a lot more
towards the expected haploid genome size
but there was a lot of fragmentation if
you think about your n 50 s relatives
and chromosome sizes they're they're not
looking very good even even with the
long read technologies the context sizes
that we're getting out of those are very
small not as small as the short reads
but at the level of smallness that it's
even challenging to kind of take some of
the other technologies and apply them to
them and the other thing is that the
long read assemblies you know were
definitely producing genomes that were
closer to capturing several of the
haplotypes not maybe all four but you
know and even in Kadel which we had
approached as a diploid
it would be simpler well it was in some
sense but still there's a lot of
heterozygosity there and enough that
with the high error rates combined with
the hetero zygosity there are a lot of
issues with actually dealing with long
reads and figuring out you know well is
this just a repeat is this Christian
high in highly arid sequence or is it
actually a divergent haplotype so anyway
when we when we finally kind of took one
of the long read assemblies as our base
then we started exploring kind of
higher-order genome scaffolding
technologies like optical maps or high C
of various flavors and what one of the
companies we worked with phased genomics
their algorithm basically you would tell
it how many chromosomes you wanted to
get out which some ways seems a little
bit of a danger sign but you know we
could tell them well we would like to
try it with 8 chromosomes would like to
try it with 32 and you can see that
there were there were some significant
differences and I will say not
differences that always made a lot of
sense to us and trying to do that I
talked a little bit about the camer
frequency spectra so you know depending
on how you what size you choose your cam
or at you will either pick up stuff that
is effectively single copy across all
the homologues and present at higher
frequencies and then smaller Peaks
representing things that are single
dosage or double dosage I think that you
know this this progression as you get
closer to you're using longer Kaymer's
and showing that your Peaks your
higher-order Peaks effectively are being
erased
you know it's effectively showing us
that they're within about 71 base pairs
you know you're going to get two snips
that actually differentiate between all
four haplotypes so it's it's quite a
complex genome to work with from an
assembly perspective but when you look
so these are the same so using 25 MERS
as our basis we're using kind of the
camer frequency plots against the
actual genomes that we've assembled and
looking to see well for Kaymer's that
are in this peak to capture them once as
expected or twice and I guess this is
actually the this is the peak of 4x
shared between all four haplotypes so
you might expect that to be captured at
4x and you know again it's not
surprising that what you see is that the
short read data tends to pick up this
you know single copy stuff and you know
some of the haplotypes are not being
represented so there at 0 X but it's
it's not really a simple picture and
even within Cadle where the the the
camera frequency plot looks a little
ragged because we don't have the same
depth of coverage because we're using
PacBio data which isn't as deep and you
can't you can't really use it prior to
correction which is one reason it
becomes less deep
I think things look complicated again as
you would expect with the hair as I
guess genome so boot busca analysis is
something that a lot of people do to
kind of assess how well their genomes
have done in terms of capturing genes
that are expected to be present in
single copy and of course whether or not
you expect it to be single copy as again
kind of relative to your expectation for
the ploidy level and the amount of time
things have had to become single copy
again following a whole genome
duplication event and you know in terms
of genic content again the short read
technologies in general well these are
different now assembly algorithms being
applied short read or long read and you
know again you can see that short read
technologies they're doing doing an okay
job of picking up gene content but just
you know basically making a single copy
whereas the longer read technologies are
picking up two or three copies of these
things and when you when you look at
genes from medicago tranquila just
across the board for things that you
wouldn't necessarily expect to be in
single copy you get a somewhat simpler
picture but definitely um
more mornings appearing in multiple you
know for four or five or higher levels
of employee so not not a real change but
kind of tendency to be able to pick
multi copy gene families I suppose
alright so we had a well we had the
medicago trunk hatchling genome and
prior evidence made from genetic Maps
within sativa showed us that essentially
the two genomes are collinear despite
the fact that even at the haploid genome
size one is quite expanded almost twice
as big as the other one there are a
couple of interesting things that turn
out not to really be about differences
between styler and Frank axilla but the
particular accession that was chosen for
the genome sequencing of trunk Atua had
some peculiarities and they they show up
when you compare it to other tran
quechuas but when you when you you know
essentially try to use trunk a chola as
your basis you would you would expect
that it would do a pretty good job of
showing you collinearity and depending
on how fragmented your assembly is you
know i genome dot plots are a nice way
of showing relationships between
different genomes but when you see
something like this where you know the
labels of one axis are so dense that you
can't even read them it basically just
means that you've got a lot of degrees
of freedom that you have to make things
look like diagonals and if there are
real structural events going on between
your your genomes you're not likely to
see them but as you as you start
applying more aggressive scaffolding
technologies then you you get the chance
to be wrong and you know this this is an
example of some of the things that we're
coming out of the hi-c data where
they're doing a pretty good job of kind
of figuring out which chromosome a
particular scaffold belongs to I'm
getting it in the right neighborhood but
effectively what they're doing even
when you you tell them to kind of
produce 32 chromosomes is not really
give you 32 chromosome haplotypes but
give you each each of the 8 chromosomes
in 4 pieces where each of the pieces
kind of represents a strange little
jumble of all haplotypes that you had
for that because the hi-c data isn't
really able of resolving these kind of
haplotype phasing issues at least not in
the hands of the algorithm that was
applied to it so just zooming in on this
a little bit more on one of the
chromosomes you can you can start to see
on the one hand probably some assembly
artifacts that are coming in and from
some of the scaffolding technologies I
would I would not expect this to be a
real relationship between a alfalfa
scaffold and trunk Angela you see
another one of those sort of crow's-feet
representations there but you can also
clearly see you know we are picking up
fairly good representation of two
haplotypes along you know in many cases
along wide stretches and in some case
it's a little bit more fragmented again
if we take if we take our original non
scaffold just long read technologies you
can start to kind of trace a picture but
you have a lot of degrees of freedom to
make make this into little you know sort
of line segments that are showing you
collinearity as you apply something like
optical mapping these lines become much
longer than more coherent and you know
these seem to represent appetites but
they're still kind of a question about
can you really trust that the phasing
that this is sort of saying that you
have along your haplotype is actually
accurate because you know by oh nano map
doesn't actually have sequence data
associated with it it's just a kind of a
pattern which we'll see in a another
slide so this this is the kind of
commish of haplotypes that the hi-c data
is producing for it for this region
again probably in the right general
vicinity but it's certainly not making a
single
here in haplotype as instructed by the
32 chromosomes and then if we apply a
high c-plus bio nano which kind of
allows you to make breaks where
necessary and you know what one one
limitation of the non sequence basis of
something like an optical map is that
your your scaffolds kind of have to be a
certain size to begin with in order for
them to get purchase into the genetic
map sorry no the optical map which I'll
show in another slide so this then again
is using using the same tool to look at
the haplotypes that we've derived from
that region and here's a just kind of
the crows foot sort of thing that we
were seeing in the dot plot looked at
from the genic perspective and turned on
its side for cattle so that that's what
I would consider to be an artifact
scaffold but we also see some kind of
interesting things within our alfalfa
blocks where you know this this is just
kind of a contact that the optical map
was not able to place probably because
it wasn't long enough and didn't have
enough restriction sites to really
create a pattern to put it into place
but you can you can basically imagine
that it fits right in there here's
another example where you have a little
region we didn't we didn't happen to
pick it up using the kind of synteny
based way of looking at things that
we're using here but another kind of
interesting question then again along
the same lines about well what what do
people who want to use in alfalfa genome
I really want out of a reference you
know the pretendin C would be to say
well let's just choose the longest
haplotype and kind of do a minimum
tiling thing and choose the most
contiguous and least redundant path
through those dot plots that we can but
there does seem to be a lot of evidence
that there's gene loss between the
different homologues as you know some
polyploid theory might lead you to
believe could be the case and so you
know if you just chose one
representative homolog then you might be
missing important gene content that was
actually present on another one of these
copies and so you know as I sort of
alluded to the fact that you've got kind
of a
a pan genome for the price of a single
genome with alfalfa and you know I'm I'm
thinking you know eventually we might
come to the place where instead of
thinking about single reference genomes
we think about consolidated references
that could basically take all the four
homologues
i've abstract them out into a single
representation that was maximally useful
for somebody actually trying to do
things in alfalfa
alright so optical maps turned out to be
a bit of a surprise for me
you know they I was thinking that they
wouldn't really have enough information
to be able to distinguish the homologues
but what we what we were seeing is that
when we took the original context and
then started placing them up against the
scaffolds that it would produce we saw
that they were kind of breaking the
context and distributing them across
different scaffolds and in a kind of a
pattern that suggested that maybe what
was going on was it was trying to make a
haplotype consistent phasing so this
this is kind of what optical maps look
like you sort of do an in silico
digestion of your sequence data that
you've produced where wherever you know
the enzymes that you're using you find
their cut sites and you look at the
pattern that this would create and then
you look at all of the labeled molecules
that you've put together using assembly
like techniques and look at the patterns
that they show and so in this case we
can kind of see some clear regions where
maps created using different enzymes are
showing places where you get a very
clear crossover between the sequence
scaffold showing a pattern that's
associated with this map up to here and
this map up to here and then switches
over to not matching this one but
matching this other one which hadn't
measured before so that seems to be
pretty good evidence in my mind these
things are actually heterozygous enough
that the haplit haplotypes are actually
fairly well distinguished even when you
don't have the sequence information so
finally you know we're
we're trying to make use of these
genetic maps and even that's been a bit
of a challenge because the the markers
that were developed were developed using
one of the short read assemblies and so
those short reader assemblies kind of
represent little mosaic haplotypes even
within the context of you know fairly
short stretches of most flanking
sequence so what you'd kind of like to
do is to say well you know I know this
was a snip chosen because it had three
copies and you know three of the
homologues at one copy of an allele and
the other one so what I really want to
do is establish you know what's the
informative allele which linkage group
did it go to and do up it within the
context of the linkage phased sort of
representation of those snips am I also
phasing those particular alleles within
the context of sequence analysis and so
this is showing us a dot plot where the
different 32 linkage groups genetically
are being represented and you can you
can see that it's it's fairly collinear
with a little bit of noise off the
diagonal showing where a particular
allele you know really ought to be in
this linkage group that was actually put
into a scaffold with something else that
it doesn't really want and then finally
getting down to the actual sequence
level of the haplotypes it was a bit of
a surprise to me to see that at the end
of the day even though we didn't really
end up using
Kadel to be kind of a substrate for
working on the higher level putting
together of the tetraploid genome when
you start looking at the haplotype
structure that you have in terms of the
different things appearing in these two
genomes there actually it seems as
though you're seeing in some cases at
least similar haplotypes resolving out
of those two genomes which tamaak tum' i
I don't I don't know that much about the
history of Keadle but I don't think was
actually really derived in any way from
this material so that was kind of a nice
result and then up here we're kind of
showing what a most
sequence alignment tool for whole
genomes kind of does when you try to
give it things that actually have
multiple genome copies but you're just
sort of saying well you know take take
this species and align it here and I
expect there to really be one region but
it's finding it's finding that you've
given it several copies of this region
with different characteristics it's kind
of just mashing them into one consensus
like thing that is much more nicely
resolved down here alright so this is
the kind of the last example this
represents more recent work that it's
actually just a proposal that was
recently submitted that we've been
generating a lot of preliminary data on
and so you know people have been looking
at functional genomics omics data in
both tissues for a long time now and one
will you know it's great it's powerful
it provides us with a lot of information
but one problem is that you know in fact
you've got a genome that in some sense
is the same in all of these parts of the
plant but it's doing different things
and you know when when you aggregate
things together you can obviously miss
interesting things that might be going
into parts and sometimes you can usually
just get patterns which are actually the
opposite when you look across the
aggregate then the things within the
meaningful subgroupings that you had
might might have related and that's
called Simpsons Simpsons paradox so the
question is you know well if we start
looking at things at fine finer levels
of resolution within a system a
multi-cellular complex system will we be
able to answer questions that we
couldn't address when we were just
looking at things in the aggregate and
this is this is work that mark LeBeau
has been spearheading
so that just kind of giving a little bit
more substance to what I was saying you
know the root systems of these various
species although they have in many cases
the same cell types where cell type I'll
just let you decide for yourself what
that might actually mean they look
pretty different in terms of their
structure and the number of components
of different types that they have so you
can kind of easily imagine that when
you're averaging out in kind of
different weighted averages across these
different pools you would not really be
able to compare all that easily across
them in meaningful ways if you wanted to
say look at even if you had done a kind
of a carefully controlled experiment
where you defined you know what what is
the section of the route that is
homologous and Arabidopsis to mikado so
these other things you know you may just
be limited in terms of the actual
biology in terms of what what averaging
is happening and so when you try to do
comparisons in terms of evolutionary
questions you just might not really have
great data to work with
so recently as I'm sure many of you are
aware technologies that have been around
in the animal space for a number of
years have just begun to be applied to
plants you know it's not it's not that
we're slow on the uptake it's that we've
had you know real challenges in terms of
cell walls and the ability to actually
take plant tissue and dissociate the
cells into say contexts in which you can
actually do single cell biology but
within the last year a number of papers
have come out including John chief
Williams on the previous slide who's
looked at a rabbit opposite root
development for many years he published
a paper using proto plasting on Arab
adopts of root cells and basically
created a Arab adopts us root Atlas from
that data as a number of groups other
groups have been looking at and the eye
recently made aware of an effort that's
there's a workshop happening soon to
kind of start thinking about what it
really means to generate a plant cell
Atlas similar to the sorts of atlases
that are being developed in say human
and mouse other systems that are a
little bit more mature in terms of these
technologies so I think it's a really
exciting area and something that you
know I'm hoping that we'll get funded to
work on so Mark's approach has been a
little different in that he's he's
working with single nucleus data rather
than single cell or protoplast in single
cell data and a number of the possible
advantages to doing that are enumerated
here so it's one of the ways that I
relate this to the basic question of
polyploidy and thank Jeff Doyle for
turning me on to this question about
what happens you know transcriptionally
with cells that have different pendopo
including levels you know a lot of these
platforms will have different biases in
terms of cell cell sizes that they're
able to actually incorporate into their
micro fluidics or their droplets and so
that's that's at least somewhat
minimized with the use of nuclear data
but I think I think at the end of the
day it's probably just the fact that you
don't have to tune your system as much
when you're trying to go across
different species working with the Knife
nuclear isolation protocols so hopefully
we will be at a point soon where we can
actually engage in some of the
comparative functional omics that we are
hoping that these technologies will
really start to bring to bear on these
questions and we're you know we're
thinking that a lot of the
biological questions you know it may
actually have slightly different kind of
takes that you get when you're when
you're restricting yourself to what's
going on and nucleus but that that could
be viewed you know in some cases is an
advantage rather than you know possibly
just a difference there are some some
real challenges to you know your when
you're going to the single-cell level
you're already faced with challenges
with really low amounts of starting
material and when you when you're
limiting yourself to only what's going
on from the nucleus it's it's even more
challenging but you know the one basic
question with using the single nucleus
approach is well can we even get a
picture of these systems that's
comparable in some ways to what's coming
starting to come out of the single-cell
studies and so these are the kinds of
pictures that are created by some of the
informatics systems associated with
single-cell essentially each data point
is an individual cell and they're being
spread out into this kind of
two-dimensional projection you you can
think about this sort of like a PCA
except PCAs are kind of designed to look
at the dimensions that maximize variance
across well what are the dimensions
across which most variants occurs these
techniques are a little bit more in
tuned with looking at complex sorts of
relationships where neighborhoods are
more important T Snee was the one that
people kind of started out using I first
heard about it a couple of years ago tag
and already it's been kind of started to
be deprecated in favor of more
sophisticated techniques but in any case
you can see that if you if you do kind
of a coke clustering that takes into
account kind of possible batch effects
between the different experiments and
then you project them into the same
space and then separate out the single
cell dots from single nucleus dots you
get you get a fairly you know coherent
picture in terms of the overall
structure where different areas are
populated by both cells in nuclei
but there are some things that we're
picking up that don't seem to be present
at all in the in the single-cell data so
that it could be a case in which there
are just certain cell types that are
biased for whatever reason against being
picked up in a fair plasting approaches
that we're able to pick up with the
nuclei when when it so it's you know
it's fun to look at these plots
sometimes it's okay if you can see four
patterns but at the end of the day what
you really want to do is to sort of
figure out well what are these cell
types and so if you're working in a
rabid OPS's you know you have marker
genes that have been established for
cell types over many years and you can
use the patterns of expression to kind
of tease apart what these clusters
likely represent biologically similarly
in soybean which is paleo polyploid were
we're able to sort of do do a similar
thing figure out what the clusters
represent and then start to look at
effects of treatments like inoculation
with sim buy on and show differential
expression between the genes that are in
the same cluster but being affected by
the treatments differently and so I
probably won't have too much time to
talk about this but you know Jeff and I
have worked since the early days of NGO
sequencing on questions around well when
you get when you get new polyploids
being formed from hybridization of
diploid x'
and you come polyploid complexes
essentially you call them Aalto until a
but they're really different species
different genomes different combinations
of genomes what actually happens with
the expression of these homeotic gene
ohms together and can you access those
questions using some of these sequence
of sync technologies where sometimes you
see you know one one homolog effectively
gets suppressed and the other one is
sort of dominant sometimes you get
things like sub functionalisation and so
we're trying to take the single-cell
data and basically ask those questions
by taking
the data from the single cells that's
been aggregated across the clusters and
then defining indices that describe in
terms of gene pairs related to one
another through homie OG from ancient
whole genome duplication events you know
what what are the sorts of patterns that
you can see so this is a case where for
this particular gene pair sometimes one
gene is the dominant partner sometimes
the other gene is the dominant partner
and sometimes you don't see any bias so
you don't have enough read count data to
really see significant bias
sometimes you see clear preference one
home you log over another and then
similarly you know our different tissues
different in terms of the ways in which
they use different homologs to become
the cells that they want to be through
the developmental processes so finally
you know in addition to transcriptomic
data we're using attack seek data which
really is looking at chromosome
structure and how how the chromosomes
remodel themselves through interaction
with the histones to try to make gene
expression possible so there are some
integrative techniques that have been
developed similar to you know what you
might use when you're trying to
integrate say data set from one species
to data set from another species you're
kind of making some assumptions about
you know what expression would look like
with respect to the accessibility and
genes that are being expressed
integrating that way and then trying to
figure out what the clustering is and
then you can start asking questions
about differential accessibility over
the attack seek data aggregator across
your clusters attack seek being even
more sparse than the RNA seek data is so
here are the people who I haven't
already mentioned and of course this
talk and just like to acknowledge on the
various projects take questions
[Applause]
[Music]
so I don't think a large amount of
genetic kind of are whether or not it's
missing pieces that actually contribute
a lot so you know I would say it's not a
question we've looked at carefully yet
we haven't actually done a gene
annotation of the tetraploid mostly just
for reasons of running out of funding so
the data I was presenting was actually
taking the trunk actual genes and just
projecting them onto the tetrachloride
showing it from that perspective so
there's a little bit of guesswork
involved at that but you know in terms
of the seeing fairly large deletions
present in genic regions when you look
at individual examples I would I would
guess that it's not not uncommon to see
those types of mutations changes being
being maintained with him finding in
terms of the similarity and self
clusters between right well that is a
question I unfortunately can't address
at this point mark mark has been very
active in sort of taking the marker
genes that he's
studied and just establishing the
identity of the cell clusters and I
think you know our soybean data isn't
yet that it's not as good as our Arab
Dobbs data you know I said I said that
the the nuclear data would involve less
protocol tweaking but I think there is
some protocol tweaking just in terms of
basics sizes of nuclei for the larger
genome he mentioned something about
centrifugation being an issue so I'm
imagining that there are some bursting
issues that he's still working this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu